it's a copy after squid games and so
when you kind of even just see like the
outfits the the money and things this is
literally a modernday version of squid
game warning this episode may contain
content that is not suitable for
children viewer discretion is advised
okay so right off the bat we're going to
discuss something that's making quite a
splash in our in our population right
now what do you what do you see about
the Beast game in this poster what does
this poster tell you money money money
yes money we got money we got cars we
got we got competition for the money it
seems like competition MH what about
destruction yeah definitely destruction
so money in his hand and he's holding a
button he's going to blow it up I don't
know it's kind of an interesting image
yeah do you guys much about this show
yes not a lot yes I I have uh been
watching it with my family the past few
weeks so it's sold as the craziest show
with the craziest
jackpot um jackpot jackpot five million
nobody's ever given away that much money
$5 million plus a private island on a
game show really on a game show yeah
this is the this is the most money
that's ever been offered on a game show
w wow and it it's interesting because
you know they psychologically profiled
all these people when they when they
pulled them in here I mean really yeah
they they they they had a questionnaire
one that would say are you a hero or are
you a villain are and the questions were
really interesting why they chose um who
they chose but what do you notice about
the on their chest numbers of numbers
like prisoners numbers football players
or okay I think there's a good there's a
reason for that but I'm going to play
you a little clip right here this is
what this show is about for anybody that
has not known what this show is about
they're competing for five mill
right here I am standing on $5 million
the grand prize of the most insane
competition show you've ever seen and
competing for it are these 1,000
contestants so you got all these people
that come out they gotten only numbers
on their chest no names why do you think
they did that dehumanize them yeah just
a number and it's interesting one of the
first activities that they were going to
ask him to do um was was kind of really
interesting with the numbers
specifically but as each one of these
contestants this is kind of the first
time they come out there's a thousand of
them in this room and they're asked what
would you do with the money listen to
this I grew up homeless and now I want
to help other homeless kids and that 5
million would mean everything to help me
get there if I win $5 million I could
use that to make passive income for the
rest of my life it would provide me the
opportunity to retire my dad difference
that money can make and how it can
support a community completely getting
my whole family out of the poverty
pipeline there's a lot of clowns that
want to donate the money I'm buying jet
skis and gold chains I will die for this
I will die for $5 million this is going
to be crazy right off the bat in the
very first um thing that they had him do
um you know you're seen people going hey
I would help people I would do this with
the money that's a good thing right I
think a lot of people have have good
intentions in the in the onset MH but
when you start to see how this thing
actually plays out and people don't
really care about the people around them
you know mhm that that's a really
interesting perspective and I don't want
to judge anybody or throw anybody under
the bus but it's true how you see and
these people might have that you just
saw that wanted to do something good
they might have had that intention all
along I mean there's a thousand people
playing so it could be other people that
had a different reaction later on but
it's interesting that people are like
well I want to do something good and
then later on it's just like you I'm
going to do good for those people but
you I'm not doing good for you again I'm
not saying that these people
specifically were like that I'm just
saying in general as a concept you know
I'll do good to these people at what
cost at your cost yeah yeah at the cost
of you losing this game I willon do good
to you but I will sacrifice you to do
good to you yeah so in the beginning I
don't think people were naturally
thinking okay I'm gonna like you know uh
basically throw everybody under the bus
so I can win yeah but when the gamees
play out yeah it's interesting here's a
here's a thing that they did with the
numbers though um it's a copy after
squid games and so when you kind of even
just see like the outfits the money and
things this is literally a modernday
version of squid game it I I've seen
this before where he has the track suits
and stuff in his YouTube videos with the
numbers so yeah it's a complete C all
the all the guys are masks yeah exactly
the guys that brought out the money that
were the thing on their face um so squid
games do you know much about squid games
I have heard about it I have friends who
have watched it I myself couldn't get
myself to watch it because of probably
the same reason uh most people won't
like to watch the Beast games because of
all this like emotional roller coaster
people think it's like morally wrong or
it's just like it's to1 well give me
give me give me the one minute pitch
here in Squid games they're basically
competing but they're killing other
people right right squid games there's a
a bunch of people who have gone broke
and they need money and they're offered
this opportunity to play child games in
order to win in a bunch of money right
like 45 billion Korean money and what
they don't know is that if you lose
these games you die so it's life or
death in these games and your portion
goes to the pot and your P yeah and and
the PO portion of the person keeps going
to to whoever the winner is the grand
priz right so you're basically playing
child
games um to win all this money while
these other people who lose the games
will die here's one of the first
challenges that they had he'll kind of
explain what happens um they're going to
do some bribes to people what do you
think I'm going to be having you guys do
it's going to be a a bride that is
correct this game is the final hurdle
between you and moving on in this
competition I will be offering bribes
and whichever person accepts it will
eliminate themselves and their rows
their whole row their whole row so now
how do you feel about this morally I
mean it's a game but in the beginning
it's like look if if you take the bribe
right away then you just kicked out
everybody in that row just so you you
could make a little bit of money but
then you just took everybody else's uh
object out of the pretty selfish I would
say but at the same
time that's what's going to happen in
the end if you win you have to take out
everybody in order to win so whether you
do it early on or whether you do it
later the outcome is the same yeah you
know I we we did an episode once uh it
was about oh it's it's it's one of our
best views episodes ever it's currently
pinned to our homepage on YouTube I'll
put a link in the description um but in
in this episode there was the story of
this Dutch man who was persecuted for
his faith by you know the the church in
power during the time this this time of
the Reformation the Catholic church and
this Dutch man was a Protestant and he
was running for his life in snow over
ice in the
Netherlands and the guard who was trying
to catch him and kill him fell through
the ice and this man ran back at the
risk of his own life safe the guard then
got um arrested again and K and and like
murdered basically but he like gave his
own life to save his enemy wow wow I you
know I I think in the in the space that
we're in in the end of the world here
right we are supposed to be developing
Christlike characters and I think
something like this is just literally
promoting that I got to get mine before
you got to get yours mentality like like
I'm in here for me not for anyone else
and I'm going to get this I think our
ancient battle that goes all the way
back to the beginning is against self
mhm and this is just something that is
making people make decisions on self
have you ever heard the quote the
biggest battle ever fought is the battle
against self right as Christians we are
supposed to die to
self and and um there's a verse that
says that that no one has greater love
than this but to lay down your life for
your brethren you know friend yeah when
you start filtering things through the
lens of the Bible you start going this
is kind of messed up yeah look at how
people start treating this now um they
start uh when they're told this is
what's going to happen you're going to
make everybody else in your Rogue go out
listen to what people start to do almost
immediately the room erupted in chaos
and people started to introduce one
another by their name my name's Jonathan
aleandro that's my name and not their
number why do you think they would say
tell their name to people well they
wanted to probably befriend one another
to see if they could trust each other
and not get the bride the bride a name
begins to add a relationship to people
right this whole experience that we have
on this planet is a relationship
experience and it's interesting now
these guys are starting to go okay I'm
not just a number anymore this is my
name I'm a real person yeah don't
eliminate me like I'm nothing I have a
story yeah and they're psychologically
now trying to Prime everybody else in
their row don't sell us out hey I know
your name you know my name all this kind
of stuff it's kind of interesting yeah
so listen to what happens but sometimes
the people who you think you can trust
the
most are actually oh my the people you
can trust the
[Applause]
least he took the money and now
everybody in his row has got to go home
with nothing but he's like I got the
money dude I'm happy Grand and not only
that if you've watched the the episode
uh he was the guy that it was done in
the edit they were making the viewers
were think that he was super trustworthy
they were putting an emphasis on him
saying no amount of money is going to
take me out right so you trusted it so
as the audience you are also very
disappointed so now you're making people
distrust each other in this game so not
only you making them selfish you're now
playing with their relationships and
breaking their relationships dude Satan
trust anyone Satan's emo is divide and
conquer that's his emo but this isn't
everyone not everybody has this
experience and and as you see this play
out there are some people that were like
you know what I'm not going to take the
bribe or whatever um and that that that
becomes apparent but I found it really
interesting that they separated them
into a couple different groups and they
had them pick team captains and then
they would offer them money and that
money would continue to increase until
you press the button but if you press
the button everyone on your team has to
go home so and only you get the money
only you get the money so here's what
happens can you find someone on your
team that money can't buy you are crazy
did you really need to you need to chill
they will be tempted with an insane
amount of money whatever you're thinking
it is going to be higher than that
they're going to tell you they won't
crack but we will find that breaking
point so let's distill down what he's
actually doing he's making the group
pick someone based on trust and then
he's going to bribe them to the point
where he's going to try to make them
sacrifice their entire team I think
that's kind of evil yeah and I think
that I think the the world is
recognizing like yeah this is kind of
messed up you know it's like it's a sad
reflection of of of our state of affairs
that we're in in the human race yeah I
find it interesting that guy next to him
his name is Mack it's it's an
interesting reaction that he has to Mr
Beast being like dude you're crazy yeah
yeah so here it is they pick the pick
the guys and actually ironically they
did not take the bribe check this out
there are literally four people
currently saying no to half a million
dollar500 Grand what is going on it's
over a half a million dollars are you
guys chronically insane so they're
tempting them it's getting higher
they're obviously adding emotion into
the scene and they get all the way up to
almost a million dollar would that be
pressure for you if you were in that
seat I I mean I I I mean I I think it
would be pressure for anybody M you you
always would like to think I wouldn't do
that right but until you're in the
situation I think it's hard to to make
that judgment call on somebody else and
they all have their different Back
stories as well like one of the guys was
like homeless the other one was a
retired fireman it's like the pressure
is different for every guy with the
Beard's a Christian yeah but and you
think about it it you know you might not
win the 5 million so you get 1 million
or you get nothing that's that's going
through your head yeah but I think I
think you just got to pray through it if
if you are part of this for some reason
you are a participant I I would pray
like Lord I want to honor you help give
me to strength because I can't do this
without you that's a huge Temptation
right but we have games that we're
trying to tempt people that's
interesting to me now do you want a
undergrad Jeremy's turning around
looking at the screen a little bit now
the viewers are going to think this is
fake this is real nine 100 oh my God oh
my oh my surely somebody has to take it
it's almost a million
dollar yeah so the entire team is is is
betting on that the person they chose is
not going to take it and I I actually
was was pleased that they didn't take it
praise God you know what I mean like I
don't know I just don't I just don't
like the idea of someone being shady and
it's like you're kind of watching this
thing play out and they're kind of being
shady with each other um but here's
here's a little clip from like a lot of
the different games and stuff like that
listen to what begins to happen because
remember in the beginning of this
conversation people were like oh I would
help all these people and do all this
kind of stuff now look at what they're
doing to each other to try to get this
again we do have to say we don't know if
those begin people who said in the
beginning are the same people here I do
want to be respectful of that you can
feel the tension y'all are both selfish
why would you go against the team my
heart is broken into pieces right now I
don't trust anyone I'm here for myself
and my family
everything is on the line the Mind Games
have begun which one of these players
will make entertainment history and win
$5 million do whatever it takes there's
only going to be one
winner and it all comes down to
[Music]
this so you can see them saying why you
being selfish why you do this the
relationship's being broken shattered
it's like you can't trust anybody I mean
this for
me and whoever you think you can trust
the games will make sure you don't trust
them anymore yeah we'll have instances
where you know they have like oh make
sure uh make teams of three and then
they all go and gather with their best
friends and then in the background Mr be
goes like little do they know they're
going against each other and nobody's
going to be friends anymore right I saw
uh there was a Mr Beast where they took
a bunch of twins and they had some
competitions with the twins and they
were like pitting them against each
other and stuff and you think about that
family is a very close Bond you know and
it's like a lot of his shows he has this
kind of a thing I'm going to see how
crazy people can be in certain
circumstances and yeah you wonder I mean
taking a sta at being armchair
psychologist for a moment he's in a very
unique position as an individual there's
basically almost nobody on YouTube who
can compete with him yeah and in that
respect he's very much alone MH right
so if he's alone in this almost even
bigger
competition you know what what Joy does
he get out of life have you seen those
clips talking about him and his
experience and like being a YouTube
Creator over years and years and he's
just like he's
obsessed with his YouTube craft and he
knows that nobody can touch him there's
he's like at the top and there 's nobody
to compete with him mhm you just have to
go bigger and bigger and bigger and here
he's this isn't the first time he's done
games if you look at his channel you can
see the titles and and things that he've
done he's done other games smaller games
and now he's just escalating the
situation but it's it's like if you look
at this what is he doing with other
people is he putting them in the same
situation that he centrally is in
putting them through the same emotions
and and you know psychological things
that he has to go through himself and
and he's getting I don't know is he
getting joy out of watching somebody
else go through the same thing that he's
going through yeah I I I really I really
think this is sad that our society is is
getting entertainment off of somebody
else's tragedy and and it's almost like
we're like you know it's not a new idea
it's not a new idea lots of game shows
have done this but I think this kind of
put that front and center with me going
okay as a Christian what are we supposed
to be doing in in the the world right
now we're supposed to be reflecting the
character of Christ which is which is
very loving and and very you know
self-sacrificing kind of a thing yeah
and here it's kind of almost just the
opposite trying to Foster People to be
selfish or greedy in Rome that's the way
it was they used to get enjoyment out of
other people's destruction at the cost
of their own lives we're going to get to
that yeah we're going to get to that all
right so here's what um The Guardian has
to say about this I think it's very
interesting because this actually hasn't
gotten a lot of very good reviews did
you know that there's a lot of people
that are like dude this is wrong this is
messed up this is just like bad here's
what the um the guardian says uh denique
go read this it exists solely to show us
the worst of the human condition as
obnoxiously as possible that's a
scathing rebuke and the worst of the
human condition is utter selfishness
right greed selfishness interestingly
enough though he put two of five stars
on the top little graphic I'm like so
there's something worse right right
right right right I thought that was
pretty interesting James 3:16 is a verse
that uh we've talked about on the show
quite a bit and and it's like where
there's envy and self-seeking confusion
and every evil thing is there and I
think that what's really crazy is right
now we're seeing this game come out into
the open we talked about it being a
ripoff of squid gam squid games coming
out again and these are these are things
that are not fostering good
relationships it's tearing them apart
the Bible also says in Philippians 2 3
and 4 do nothing from selfish ambition
or conceit but in humility count others
more significant than yourselves Let
each of you not look to your only his
own interest but also to the interest of
others I'll tell you this though there
were moments in this game that I was
pleased to see people if they self
ejected out of there their whole team
could go on and there was people that
voluntarily said I'd like my team to
have the opportunity and I'll be the one
to leave M and I was like yes thank you
okay we're not all lost there's actually
some good people out there that are that
are literally like you know thinking of
other people and not just their own skin
so I want to be fair to the show there
were some people that that had that kind
of attitude but squid games is is is
sort of just even taking what Mr Beast
is doing one step further obviously not
just kicking people out but taking their
life yeah yeah dude and you think about
like Jesus came to this planet to give
us life and to give it abundantly what
wouldn't you do to save your life your
own life yeah if you're not in
connection with God right it's like it's
like you said earlier denique like No
Greater Love Is there than to lay your
own life for your friend but if you
don't have that love what wouldn't you
do what dirty trick wouldn't you do
every dirty trick counts in war the
opposite of love is to step on somebody
or take their life or sacrifice them so
that you can achieve a higher status
Hollywood there's enough videos out
there of people talking about Hollywood
stars sacrificing people or family
members or whatever to move up that
ladder and if you think about it it's
the most opposite end of the spectrum of
what true love is somebody that's laying
down their life I would I would give my
life so that so that my friend could
live on or something like this that's
like the ultimate demonstration of love
right that's what Christ did for us yes
but sacrificing someone else so that you
can live that's literally the bottom
opposite side of that Spectrum yeah and
also if you think about in the grand
scheme of things where are we headed as
as a planet as a world as a Humanity we
are so close to the second coming of
Christ but that gets preceded by
absolute Terror end of the world AP cpse
stuff basically because the mark of the
beast is going to come the ultimate test
to allegiance to God or to yourself
which is ultimately to Satan and so if
when you watch this kind of stuff you're
constantly having seeds planted in you
you need to be you need survive all the
fittest you need to go for yourself go
for yourself right like even to like
saving your own life when Revelation 13
talks about those who will follow Jesus
will be killed for their faith but if
you're constantly having seeds planted
in your brain you need to choose self
how do you think you're going to
actually stand up for Jesus if this is
um something that is highly watched in
our world because squid games is a very
like highly watched show right I mean
this is this is not a small amount of
people that are paying attention to this
and now you've got Mr Beast and I think
another thing that Keith showed me um
was Call of Duty and now we're talking
about the video game world that's adding
this same layer in there so check this
out game show priming the pump with with
people being selfish and people being
whatever M squid games taking it one
step further instead of just getting
kicked off the show you're going to die
now you got a video game that's based on
this same premise now you're actually
making the decision of who dies look at
this trailer this is messed
up introducing the new Call of Duty
event pass featuring squid
[Music]
game play the squid game event pass to
earn new
[Music]
rewards compete in all modes and earn
player XP to level up through the event
pass upgrade your event pass for more
rewards including the Ultimate
Prize wow I have one thought one thought
the Bible says by beholding we become
changed this is not just a Biblical
concept it's a scientific concept we
have in our brain something called
mirror neurons monkey see monkey do if
you do something right now and I see you
shooting somebody my brain cannot
register the difference between you
doing it or myself doing it so first you
have the show while you're watching
people do it and now you take it a step
further while you're actually playing
like you're doing it it's even worse
every single image that they showed in
this show or this video game what are
they actually doing is anybody building
something no anybody helping someone
entire premise destruction yes cut down
kill shoot and if you're sitting there
playing with that and you're taking
pleasure now in the death of people I
want you to follow this logic M you're
taking pleasure in people like you know
losing out on getting a prize then squid
games is bringing it to the level of now
you're taking pleasure when oh yeah I
didn't really like that guy anyway and
now he's dead to now you're just
literally take everyone out and I need
to be the last man standing this
literally to me is how I believe that
they arrived at this perspective Ive in
Rome mhm I think they dehumanized the
Christians so much that there were
people that were actually coming to
these things like a sporting event
eating popcorn and drinks and no
probably not popcorn but you know what I
mean like they're they're they're making
it a festival a fun environment to watch
people called bread and circus bread and
circus that's how they they called it I
remember you made a comment about this
where you're like oh imagine that
they're sing in a Coliseum and it's like
you know the popcorn comes in and like
oh I want some popcorn Oh shoot what did
I miss oh some of these just died but
this is happening in our living room
yeah it's the same concept you go to
your kitchen you're like what did I miss
oh so and so got killed oh okay it's the
exact same thing and we think we're any
better than the people in the Coliseum
were the same thing right you you
brought up the um the last supper and
you know the disciples and stuff that
are arguing about who's number one at
that time they're like literally in the
presence of Jesus they are you know just
about to witness the culmination of the
Plan of Salvation coming down and dying
on a cross for for them and they're just
trying to figure out who's best who's
number one who can sit at the right hand
who's the who's the top dog and you know
this this is is where I believe the end
of the world will get back to this
position but I think they're priming the
pump for people to not care about each
other to only save your own skin and and
um and you can see it in the imagery too
because the guards you know they're
they're faceless yeah it's true yeah
it's like you have no identity that's
it's you know and part of Call of Duty
Black Ops 6 I think is the element of
zombies which is that same kind of thing
you know this dehumanization you know
just one track mind not good for
anything they only do things a certain
way think a certain way group think
mentality all of that is is part of the
package you know it reminds me of
something that the Bible says in 2
Thessalonians chapter 2 speaking about
the last days it says and for this
reason God will send them strong
delusion that they should believe the
lie that they all may be condemned who
did not believe the truth but had
pleasure and
unrighteousness you know what do we take
pleasure in do we take pleasure in
unrighteousness or do we love the truth
that's a question that we all have to
ask ourselves in the times that we're
living um and you know it's easy to take
this text and say well well God's the
one making them believe a lie or
something no is if you really understand
the whole uh entirety of the Bible this
isn't god making anybody believe
anything but allowing those
circumstances to happen which you're
choosing to believe the lie you're
choosing the
delusion so it's a decision it's you
have decis you have to make God is not
removing your your freedom of choice on
what you believe but yeah you're going
to pick a direction either truth or
pleasure and unrighteousness amen well I
hope you guys got a blessing out of this
conversation and uh we we're curious of
your thoughts so definitely leave us a
comment and uh as always remember uh you
know to reflect Christ's character that
is that is literally where we need to
spend our time learning about how Jesus
was was you know literally giving his
his coat off of his back to help
somebody else and and those are the
things that we need to be doing is
spending our time uh building up
relationships not tearing them apart and
uh you know especially these kind of
things that you're having entertainment
and and getting pleasure off of other
people like losing out or or even
getting killed um those those things are
things that we want to steer clear of so
we hope you guys like this and give us a
thumbs up and check out some of our
other videos if you haven't checked them
out already and we'll see you guys on
the next LED live sh
[Music]